so when I talk to the guy or to women in
say Robert kiyosaki's organization and
they're you know 29 maybe they're 31
years old now going Rolo I can't find a
good guy I did everything right I did
everything that Society told me that I
was supposed to do I got the career I
got my degree I'm working in Rich Dad
Poor Dad I've got real estate
Investments I've got all this money I've
got this but um but I can't find a guy
who who wants to get on board with me
and go into the future and have babies
and everything else and I go yeah
because you become the man that you
wanted to marry yeah and by the way
that's not a Rolo tomasi quote that's a
glorious Steinem quote from 1970 that
we're still using today and it's still
just as accurate today the problem is is
now the context is a bit different
because there's so many women just like
that who are wondering how do I get a
guy well
the problem is is I know I tell them
this as well as I said you need to get
in touch with your feminine side